four three two
one ladies and gentlemen take your seats
have your first drinks
please come down it's been a long wait
for this pub in london
but it was ready to open its doors the
moment restrictions were lifted after
midnight
on april 12th and for these pub goers it
was not a moment too soon
yeah it's been too long uh i haven't
seen these like
uh socially for a while and um yeah it's
just good to be
well not this time but it's good to be
out
tough measures have been in place in
england and in other parts of the uk
since early january to suppress a surge
in coronavirus infections that swept the
country
late last year along with outdoor
service
at pubs and restaurants on monday gyms
and fitness studios were also
allowed to reopen as well as hair salons
and non-essential retail shops that's
good news for many businesses which have
struggled to stay afloat amid
several stretches of lockdown over the
past year
been yet really really worrying it's my
only source of income
um so it's put a lot of pressure on our
family as well
britain has had europe's worst
coronavirus outbreak
with more than 127 000 confirmed deaths
but infections hospitalizations and
deaths have all fallen
thanks to the lockdown and a mass
vaccination program that has given at
least
one dose to more than 60 percent of the
adult population
all right let's go to dw charlotte
chelsea pill she is on the story for you
charlotte mr boris johnson calling this
a major
step forward how excited are people
about these changes and
what's it like being in london today
that's right layla and i think a lot of
people would agree with boris johnson
today this
feels like a major step forward it has
in fact been months
since people have been able to gather
like this in pubs
outdoors feels like they've been closed
forever almost
for the people who are gathered here
they tell me but of course it's not just
for the good
good news for the people who are wanting
to have a couple of drinks here today
it's also great news for the pub owners
they've had a very very difficult time
we know that across england
lots of jobs thousands of jobs have been
lost businesses
have closed so a good news here today it
does feel like a major step forward
for people hoping for at least some
semblance of normality to return
um yes obviously a lot of optimism there
where you are but
health officials continue to warn that
people should not become complacent
because there are still
many variants that are spreading uh
quickly what restrictions will remain in
place
that's right the government here is
still urging caution today reminding
people
that there are still these restrictions
in place now
some uh of the lockdown measures are
being used as you can see
a lot of others remain for example
indoor dining
at pubs and restaurants not allowed at
the moment there's a big indoor space
just behind me
which has to remain empty there are also
limitations on
the number of people who can gather
outside indeed the number of people that
you can
you can't mix with other households in
your own home
a lot of restrictions still in place
here that's because boris johnson the
prime minister has said he wants
the easing of restrictions to be
cautious but
irreversible so it is happening in a
multi-step
plan with a goal in five weeks to
unleash more restrictions
and then more going forward in june as
well right and what about the rest of
the country
charlotte how is the rest of the uk
doing
right well uh scotland wales and
northern ireland generally throughout
this pandemic have
broadly been in line with the rules and
regulations being put in place
in england today though it is just
england that is uh celebrating the
the uh unlocking of both outdoor pubs
restaurants hospitality and
non-essential shops as well those two
things in conjunction are unique to
england today but more measures are
going to be
unlocked in the other nations over the
coming weeks
all right charlotte chelsea phil
reporting from london thank you very
much